este proyecto aprobado por la mayoría
simple en el senado es algo positivo
para los demócratas quienes finalmente
se ponen de acuerdo y logran avanzar en
su agenda política y sus promesas de
campaña nuevamente los senadores
demócratas más conservadores como
Christian Cinema y fueron decisivos para
probar esta ley sin embargo su apoyo
estuvo condicionado a que se incluyera
entre otras cosas proyectos energéticos
y se protegiera tributariamente a
grandes corporaciones por ejemplo dijo
que cree que el país se beneficiará
porque esta ley incluye seguridad
energética para el país y eso era lo que
buscaba por su parte el líder de La
minoría republicana en el senado dijo
que la nueva ley sin embargo incluye
alzas de impuestos a empresas que van a
matar la creación de empleo y que es una
guerra contra las familias de clase
media norteamericana por su parte
economistas coinciden que a corto plazo
este proyecto no va a ayudar a la
inflación Como así lo promueven los
demócratas